Hallo Guten Tag, mein Name ist Jagir Bayram. Ich bin als Assistenz-Heirsch hier auf der Sitation. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch führen, sind Sie da mit einverstanden?
Ja Doktor, bitte schön.
Ich werde Ihnen erst ein paar Fragen zu Ihren aktuellen Daten stellen, dann direkt zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Matthias Scheuermann.
Können Sie Ihre Nachname stabilieren?
Ja, S-C-H-E-U-E-R-M-A-N. Scheuermann.
Scheuermann, Herr Scheuermann, Ihr Vornamen mit I-A-S, richtig?
Matthias, ja, genau.
Okay. Herr Scheuermann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 29 Jahre alt.
29? Waren Sie im Sigena geboren?
1. Juli 1990.
1990? Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Also ich bin 1,83 m und wiege ungefähr 65 kg.
Herr Scheuermann, was führt Sie zu uns?
Herr Doktor, das sind stechende Schmerzen und Luftnot, die ich jetzt vor 2 Stunden bekommen habe.
Und ich habe auch Husten reizt so.
Das ist das Problem, das ich habe.
Stechend auf der rechten Seite und Luftnot.
Ich merke schon, wenn ich jetzt so rede.
Ich meine Sie Brustkorb, richtig?
Brustkorb, ja.
Es ist plötzlich aufgetreten, von jetzt auf gleich.
Ich war kerngesund heute Morgen und jetzt heute Nachmittag.
Heute Abend.
Stärken, Schmerzen.
Stechend, wie Messer.
Ist das ein Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Ich habe, ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe nichts anderes gegessen, nichts gemacht.
Ganz spontan.
Haben Sie Luftnot?
Ja, ja.
Also wenn ich jetzt schneller spreche, merken Sie vielleicht auch, dass sich schon,
dass die Stimme ein bisschen Probleme bekommt.
Ich habe nicht gesehen, dass Sie auch Husten haben.
So kurz es husten, ja.
Ausruf?
Nein.
Wie gesagt, ich war kerngesund bis vor heute Nachmittag.
Ja.
Haben Sie Heißprobleme momentan, seit zwei Stunden,
meine Heißrasen oder Heißsturtern?
Kein, nur habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein, also kann ich nichts sagen.
Haben Sie sonst noch weitere Beschwerden?
Haben Sie noch etwas mehr?
Nein, das ist das Hauptproblem.
Sie haben seit zwei Stunden Stärke in den rechtseitigen Brustkotchen.
Ja.
Und Husten.
Ja, ich meine Probleme.
Atemot, ja.
Wie ist Ihr Appatit?
Normalerweise.
Früher hatten Sie keine Beschwerden oder keine Auffälligkeiten.
Haben Sie Beschwerden? Nein, das ist das erste Mal.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, kein Fieber.
Haben Sie Stärfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Keine Beschwerden.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, ein- oder durchzuschlafen?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme gehabt.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder mit dem Wasserlassen?
Nein, alles gut.
Ich möchte jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrem Krankengeschicht stellen.
Mein unfassendes Bild zu erhalten.
Gibt es in Ihrer Krankengeschichte wichtige Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht ob es wichtig ist, aber ich hatte mal die Diagnose vor fünf Jahren, ungefähr, was gewesen.
Ich hatte eine Leuchttürmathode von Lupus.
Er hatte Muskelgelenkbeschwerden und auch Hautauschlag.
Ich war beim Hausarzt, er hat mich zum Spezialisten geschickt.
Die haben Biopsien gemacht und gesagt, ich hatte diese Lupus-Krankheit.
Dann habe ich eine Koalitionstherapie bekommen.
Dann war das wieder weg und seitdem habe ich auch keine Probleme mehr gehabt.
Seit wann haben Sie keine Probleme?
Zwei bis fünf, sechs Jahren war das gewesen.
Sonst haben Sie weitere Krankheiten?
Ich habe Gastritis, also Reflux, deswegen nehme ich wieder mal Medikamente ein.
Ansonsten habe ich meine Menuskosoperation gehabt vor zehn Jahren.
Bei einer Verletzung war ich aber nie im Krankenhaus gewesen.
An welchem Knie?
Rechts.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder gelegentlich Medikamente ein?
Gelegentlich nehme ich halt die Spandopazole, wenn ich so Reflex-Probleme habe.
Sonst keine Medikamente.
Wie viel Medikamente?
40 Medikamente.
Einmal total?
Nach Bedarf.
Bei Bedarf.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie sonst etwas?
Keine anderen Medikamenten?
Okay.
Haben Sie momentan Schwierigkeiten beim Atmen?
Fühlen Sie sich besser?
Brauchen Sie etwas momentan?
Oder können Sie uns halten, bis Sie unsere Aufnahmegespräch enden?
Also müssen Sie entscheiden, ich weiß nicht, ob ich etwas brauche.
Okay.
Jetzt muss ich Ihre Sauerstoffwerte überprüfen.
Also, gut haben Sie gemacht.
Oximetrie zahlt 90 Prozent.
90 Prozent.
Muss Sauerstoff werden zuführen.
Ja, kann man machen.
Okay, jetzt habe ich Sauerstoffen im Masen.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich ein bisschen besser?
Ein bisschen besser, ja. Die Luft ist besser geworden.
Können wir weitermachen?
Ich denke ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Allergien, etwas oder Unfälle?
Ich habe keine Allergien, aber ich habe damals, als dieser Lupus festgestellt worden ist,
habe ich so einen Ausweis bekommen, auf welchen Medikament ich aufpassen muss.
Das waren nur Vorsichtshalbe, aber ich habe jetzt keine bekannten Allergien oder Unverdäglichkeiten.
Okay.
Brauchen Sie?
Ja, leider.
Wie viele Geräte brauchen Sie pro Tag?
Ja, so 20, 30 Geräte, also eineinhalb Bäckchen manchmal.
Wie seit wann brauchen Sie?
Oh, ich habe mit so 16, 17 angefangen.
10 Jahre, 12 Jahre vielleicht.
10 Jahre, okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nur bei Annästen, also vielleicht am Wochenende mal Wein, sonst nicht regelmäßig.
Okay, nehmen Sie nicht bitte persönlich, das ist rhythmische Frage.
Konsumieren Sie Abdrohungen?
Nein, ich nehme keine Drohungen zur Zeit ein.
Ich habe früher mal probiert ein bisschen, als ich jung war, mit Excessive,
aber das war damals noch, wo ich jung war, aktuell keine Drohungen.
Gibt es in Ihrer Alter ein wichtiger Erkrankungen, von denen ich es tun sollte?
Also mein Vater hatte Rheumar gehabt.
Er ist dann aber auch später bei Verkehrsunfall gestorben.
Meine Mutter lebt noch, die hat Diabetes und hat auch schon mal einen Schlaganfall gehabt,
so ein leichter, ansonsten keine weiteren Erkrankungen.
Ihr Mutter hat Diabetes-Mani-Tools, Suckerkrankheit und Schlaganfall.
Darf ich Sie fragen, wann Ihr Vater gestorben ist?
Das war vor 3, 4 Jahren Verkehrsunfall.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin Einzelkind.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin feieradet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, noch keine.
Wohnen Sie mit der Frau?
Bitte?
Was sind Sie von mir ruf?
Ich bin in der Bank als IT-Techniker.
Okay, Herr Scheuermann.
Ich habe meine ganze Frage gestellt.
Haben Sie auch mich fragen,
oder fällt Ihnen noch etwas auf?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht verstanden.
Ich habe mich nicht verstanden.
Was sind Sie von mir ruf?
Ich habe meine ganze Frage gestellt.
Haben Sie mich fragen,
oder fällt Ihnen noch etwas auf?
Nein, ich denke,
das waren die wichtigsten Sachen,
die ich Ihnen sagen konnte.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie mir auch schnell helfen können.
Ich hoffe, dass es nichts Ernstes ist.
Wenn Sie keine Fragen mehr haben,
ich möchte Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen,
die Fragen über die Weitergeschichte informieren.
Einfach.
Danke, Herr Doktor.
Gut.
Gibt es Kommentare oder weitere Fragen,
die Sie gestellt hätten?
Da es sich immer ein Notfall handelt,
sollten wir die Anmene pausieren,
eigentlich gehen machen,
um die Vitalparameter zu kontrollieren.
Das hat er gemacht.
Hatten Sie Traume oder Verletzung?
Ja, gute Frage.
Haben Sie gefragt?
Ich habe nicht gefragt, aber Herr Patient hat mir gesagt.
Hat mir gesagt, ja.
Das ist keine Ausschläge.
Trotzdem ist es eine Frage,
die man auch stellen sollte, finde ich.
Das ist die Verdachtsdiagnose.
Okay.
Hatten Sie auch so gesagt, Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja.
Spontanprämiumdorax.
Stahlen Ihre Schmerzen in andere Körperregionen aus?
Schmerz an Mese kann man machen?
Im Bereich der Brust haben Sie gefragt.
Hauptsache, rechte Brustwand.
Brustkorb.
Was gibt es noch wichtige Fragen?
Vielleicht kann man sie in den Schmerzen atmen?
Kann man fragen?
Was Sie auffragen könnten,
ob die Luftmutter schlechter geworden ist.
Warum fragt man das?
Kann eine Verschieb-Pinomateras
oder wie heißt das auch durch?
Wie heißt das auch durch?
Nicht verraten, im Chat.
Wie heißt das?
Spannungsponomatrag ist richtig.
Spannungsponomatrag.
Das ist dann eher ein bisschen Notfall.
Dann merkt, dass es schlechter wird.
Okay.
Aber das waren die wichtigsten Fragen.
Die Anamese war sehr leer.
Junge Patient, erwarten wir nicht viel.
Medikamente haben Sie gefragt.
Sonst fällt mir auch nichts ein.
Was waren die wichtigsten Sachen?
Was waren Sie mit den Patienten?
Sollen wir gleich zum Vorgehen?
Oberarztvorstellung, können Sie auch kurz machen?
Dann können wir gleich zum Vorgehen.
Darf ich anfangen?
Bitte schön.
Ich muss noch mal kurz unterbrechen.
Bei so einem Patienten,
wo Sie einen Verdacht auf spontan hat,
machen Sie Ihre Diagnostik.
Ich stelle nicht als Oberarztvor.
Meistens stellen Sie den Oberarztvor,
wenn Sie Diagnosen und Therapie schon gemacht haben.
Wir machen es andersrum.
Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen heute einen 29-Jährigen
gegen den Herrn Matthias Schäuermann vorstellen.
Der Patient ist 1. Juli 1990 geworden.
Wenn Sie 29 Jahre sagen,
das reicht schon aus,
dann ist es 1. Juli 1993.
Das hört ich gerade nicht.
Ich höre es nur 1993.
1993, 1993.
Das reicht schon, wenn Sie sagen,
19-jähriger Patient.
Oberarzt hat keine Zeit für so etwas.
Deswegen müssen Sie sagen,
1. Juli 1993.
Er ist 108 cm und 85 kg schwer.
Der Patient stellte sich bei uns,
wenn sein Sender müßlich aufgetretener,
rechtsseitige Torachschmerzen mit Husten.
Bei der Patientin
seien keine Auslöser aufgefallen.
Außerdem klagte der Patient über Dyspnoe.
Herzprobleme,
Fragen nach Herzprobleme,
wurde verneinigt.
In der vegetative Anamnese
ist unauffällig.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig.
An Vorerkrankungen
leide der Patient seit 4 Jahren Lupus erethomatosis.
Diese Krankheit sei konservativ
mit Cortisontherapie behandelt worden.
Außerdem leide der Patient
an gastroesophageal Reflehrkrankheit.
Dagegen nehme er Pantoplasol 40 mg bei Bedarf ein.
Der Patient
hat sich
Minuskeptomie vor 4 Jahren
rechts untersorgend.
Was hat er bekommen?
Wegen Minuskusrupto
Minuskeptomie untersorgend.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Minuskus ganz raus ist
oder nur zurückgeht.
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Ja, richtig.
Bei der Patientin
sei keine Allergie und Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Der Patient
braucht seit 10 Jahren 20 bis 30
Zigaretten pro Tag.
Am Wochenende
ein Glas Wein
und drogen Konsum wurde verneint.
Familienanamnästisch
fanden sich Rheuma-Erkrankungen beim Vater.
Vater
sei vor 4 Jahren wegen
Autounfall
und die Mutter leide
an Diabetes mellitus.
Sie haben
Schlaganfall
oder Apoplex gelitten.
Oder
hätte ein Schlaganfall
erlitten.
Der Patient
sei verheiratet, habe kein Kinder,
wohne mit seiner Frau.
Er arbeite als
IT-Techniker in einem Bank.
Nach den bisherigen Angaben
gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf
Pynomotorax aus.
Differenzial diagnostisch.
Vielleicht
miocardinfarkt
in den Mittag.
Zur weiteren Abkühlerung würde ich
folgende Massnahmen durchführen.
Als erstes
würde ich den Patienten
körperlich unterhalten.
Ich instiziere
den Brustkorb, ob es
symmetrisch ist.
Bei der Oskultation
achte ich darauf, ob es
Lungengeräusche gibt
oder wie Lungengeräusche ist.
Wenn ich
eine Stumlung feststelle,
dann spreche ich von einem Pynomotorax.
Was machen Sie?
Bei der Perkussion
achte ich darauf, ob es
ein gedämpfter Kopfschall ist.
Ich erwarte ein gedämpfter Kopfschall.
Ich erwarte einen gedämpfter Kopfschall.
Wo erwarten Sie ein gedämpfter Kopfschall?
Rechtszeitige
Hypersonorität
Sie erwarten Hypersonorung
Kopfschall.
Sie erwarten Hypersonorität
Hypersonorität
Was hören Sie bei der Auskultation auf der rechten Seite bei den Patienten?
Bei der Auskultation erwarte ich Sturmlunge, rechtseitige Sturmlunge.
Ja, ist das so?
Ja, da oder verminderte Lungengeräusche.
Genau, das ist häufiger, dass man ein abgeschwächtes Atemgeräusch hört.
Also, dass man gar nichts hört, ist extrem selten beim Pneumotorax.
Da muss ja schon ein kompletter Atlekt, also kompletter Kollaps sein.
Also abgeschwächtes Atemgeräusch oder aufgehobenes Atemgeräusch,
ob wie ich schon richtig gesagt worden ist.
Und wo auskultieren Sie?
Überall natürlich.
Und wo kann es sein, dass Sie auch normales Atemgeräusch haben beim Pneumotorax?
Überall auskultiere ich, aber ich erwarte am meisten
Abgeschwächtes Atemgeräusch von Lungen, diese Beschwerden oder Auffälligkeiten.
Richtig, genau, das häufigste ist ein Abgekalt.
Wo legen Sie die Städoskopien?
Wo?
Bei Abgekalt abhören?
Ja, hinter dem Klavikulier.
Superklavikulier und interkostal.
Okay.
Wenn Sie da nichts hören, ist das automatisch den Pneumotorax?
Nein, wir brauchen noch weitere.
Es ist nur für die weiteren Untersuchungen kommen,
aber es ist von Ausstattationsrufung.
Wenn Sie jetzt hier auf der rechten Seite vom Patienten, das ist hier, ja,
wenn Sie jetzt praktisch mal hier Städoskop drauf halten,
dann hören Sie nichts, also leise Atemgeräusch.
Ist da die Diagnose für Sie sicher?
Nein.
Was muss man da immer machen?
Die Seite, die Seite.
Richtig, genau, Seiten-Differenz.
Das ist genau die richtige Antwort, die ich hören wollte.
Gucken, ob Seiten-Differenz besteht.
Genau, sehr gut.
Okay, jetzt haben Sie ausgotiert.
Also Sie haben Hypersornung, Klopschall,
abgeschwächtes oder aufgerobenes Atemgeräusch
auf der betroffenen Seite.
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Noch.
Sie als Körperl-Funktage suchen?
Als allgemein diagnostische Maßnahme.
Ich körperlich haben Sie jetzt schon genug untersucht, finde ich.
Ich überprüfe zuerst Vitalparameter,
besonders Sauerstoff-Sättigung.
Genau, ja.
Wenn wir eine Sauerstoff-Sättigung, Aufgabe zu führen.
Mhm.
Die Labo-Untersuchung könnte weitere wichtige Hinweisen liefern,
wie zum Beispiel Blutgasanalyse
oder können wir auch Blutbild überprüfen.
Brauchen Sie Blutbild beim Pneumotorax?
Nein, eigentlich nicht, aber es kann eigentlich mein Maßnahme sein.
Also Labo ist das letzte,
das wir nicht denken, über Pneumotorax, gell?
Dann sollten,
um die Verdachtdiagnose so sichern,
sollten Blutkentorax veranlassen oder einbeleiten werden.
Was schreiben Sie drauf?
Blutkentorax, auf Ihre Anforderung?
In Anforderung, Rezept,
sollten wir Daten von Patienten schreiben
und beschwerden
und gewünschte Untersuchungen
und manche Beschwerden.
Genau.
Was ist die Gewünschte der Sohn hier?
Zwei Ebenen, Torex, Posteriö anteru.
Ich habe schon erwähnt,
nur Röntgenborgs in Expiration.
Ja, Expiration, Torex.
Man kann das besser erkennen.
Okay, jetzt haben Sie Röntgen gemacht.
Also ich würde auf jeden Fall bei jungen Patienten immer auch IKG schreiben
und Richtung Herzinfarkt abklären, wie Sie schon gesagt haben.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Maßnahme, die man machen sollte.
Gut, und dann haben Sie Diagnose gestellt.
Für ein Motorhax rechts.
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Wenn wir bei unsicherer Befundetüren
auch CT durchführen.
Kann man machen, ja.
Bei Bestätigung der Verdachtdiagnose sollte
Sauerstoff abgeben,
dann interventionelle Therapie beginnen.
Wir zum Beispiel Torexdrenage, Luftdrenage.
Wo machen Sie die Torexdrenage?
Zwischen von siebthes, sechster, Tripen oder Interkostal.
Also ich bin kein Chirok,
aber normalerweise habe ich gelernt,
dass man bei Pneumotox normalerweise 2. ICR
Medioclavikulale hingemacht.
Das ist das, was ich gelernt habe.
Stimmt das?
Wo sind unsere Chiroken oder Notfallmediziner?
Das ist richtig.
Normalerweise.
Wenn der Patient von der Sauerstoffsättigung gut ist,
über 95 ohne Sauerstoffgabe,
und im Röntgen will sie jetzt
einen apikalen Pneumotox von ungefähr 2 cm sehen,
würden Sie auf jeden Fall eine Trenage anlegen?
Oder was würden Sie machen?
Wenn der Patient keine Sauerstoffprobleme
oder der Pneumotrax nicht stark ist,
können wir konservativ Überwachung durchführen.
Genau, bei kleinen Pneumotrax
wenig Symptomen und geringe Dynamik.
Der Beschwerden kann man auch manchmal
nur verlaufskontrollen machen,
aber dann würde ich den Patient in der Station aufnehmen.
Also nicht nach Hause schicken.
Okay, das ist zum Thema Pneumotorx.
Was ist das gefährliche an Pneumotorrax?
Haben wir schon angesprochen?
Wir haben angesprochen, ich habe wieder vergessen.
Und?
Diese Name.
Denken Sie, wenn man nach, vielleicht erinnern Sie sich.
Spannungspneumotorrax, ja?
Spannung, ja, Spannung per Pneumotrax.
Genau, was sind das?
Spannung per Pneumotrax kann
herzliche Probleme oder
vascular Kollaps verursachen.
Ja, genau, kann zu Herz
Zeitvolumen für Verminderung und Schock aufhören.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen, was sind so Zeichen?
Was sind so Zeichen bei Spannungspneumotorrax,
welche klinischen Zeichen würden Sie erwarten?
Tragical Verschiebung nach anderen Seiten.
Ja, das sehen Sie aber nicht von außen,
wenn Sie den Patienten angucken.
Was für klinische Zeichen gibt es denn für Hinweis,
dass es spontan spannungspneumotorrax sein könnte?
Tragical Verschiebung und
nicht
seit Differenz,
wir müssen seit Differenz
von Atem, Bewegung
überprüfen.
Rein klinisch gesehen, ohne,
Sie gucken den Patienten durch Inspektion,
gibt es Hinweise, dass es ein Spannungspneumotorrax sein könnte.
Klinische Zeichen dafür,
die Sie beunruhigen würden.
Sie sehen Sie ja nicht von außen,
da sieht man ja nicht von außen,
Sie sehen Sie im Röntgen, ich meine es klinisch,
allein durch Inspektion.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe schon mal draufgeguckt,
ich habe schon, Zyanose,
Hypotonie,
Tariqadie,
zunehmende Luftnut,
eine Dynamik, dass die Luftnut immer schlechter wird.
Und bis hin zum Schock,
das sind Schockindexentwicklungen, die Patienten.
Hypotonie und Tariqadie,
das sind Hinweise,
die Sie dran denken lassen,
dass es ein Spannungspneumotorrax sein könnte.
Und da müssen Sie ganz schnell handeln.
Ich dachte eine sichtbare...
Klinische Zeichen, Inspektion, sichtbar.
Inspektion ist von außen,
das Sie sehen.
Das war gemeint, unabhängig von Röntgen
und Sachen, die Sie erzählt haben.
Also diese klinischen Zeichen.
Gut, ich gebe es dann noch Kommentare
zum Spannungspneumotorrax.
Ich gucke gerade mal nach.
Syncope, Schock, Zyrnose, Hypotonie,
Maske, Luftlösung, Spannung.
Die meisten Sachen haben wir, glaube ich, schon besprochen.
Gut, das war das Thema Spontaneumotorrax.
Gibt es aus der Anamnese Hinweise,
die Sie dazu bewogen haben,
dass Sie an diese Diagnose gedacht haben?
Oder welche an amnestigen Angaben deuten auf diese Diagnose hin?
Gab es welche?
Es gibt keine Auslöse, das ist spontan.
Und löslich aufgetretene Schmerzen,
nicht technisch Schmerzungen,
Sprich-Gespräch für Spontanpneumotorrax.
Aber gibt es Risikofaktoren für Spontanpneumotorrax?
Trifft es jeden Menschen gleich?
Junger Menschen entsteht diese Krankheit ein bisschen öfter
und schlange Personen.
Und brauchen dann eine Ursache.
Wie nennen Sie solche schlanken Patienten?
Wie nennt man das im medizinischen Fachbegriff?
Also groß und wenig Gewicht.
Kennen Sie den Fachbegriff dafür, wie die Patienten sind?
Jung, lang, groß.
Astänische Patienten.
Bei denen ist Risiko erhöht.
Und dann haben Sie gesagt, Zigaretten rauchen.
Nicht Astänische, dann Astänische.
Ohne Ä.
Astänische.
Das Ä wegmachen.
Okay.
Der Patient hatte vor sechs Jahren Lupus Ervetomaturus gehabt.
Ist Schwiders eine Rolle?
Oder hat er die Diagnose jetzt?
Oder war das nur zur Verwirrung?
Er hat keine Schmerzen mehr.
Was denken die anderen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Lupus ist sehr müde.
Wir nehmen die Joghter raus.
Wir haben eine Schaschet-Magischen-Kohidimone.